I always wonder if you go up there did
you like did anyone grow up listening to
Benzino I did
which because Benzino you would buy The
Source magazine back in the day and you
would they heat it up like a four page
ad for like the well like the thing you
understand when see I went to school in
Boston like I'm from Cambridge but I
went to school in Charlestown so like
when I'm 14
something around there that's when
I believe that Eminem and Benzino beef
is happening
and so I know different facts than other
people like I know Benzino and them is
like really like in the streets and like
they raw rappers and beat them up and
like so and NBA players
shout out to Paul Pierce shout out to
Paul Pierce my dog
um but it's like you know it's crazy
because when you have a different
understanding of somebody right like I
always feel like the fans of the fans
knew my real real real real real real
life like they would love me 20 times
more you know
um but I knew at the time like Benzino
and them are really on that type of time
right so even if his raps wasn't the
illest [__] in the world you kind of you
you believed it so it was more it's like
you ever had a brand new hang around and
he's a killer but he's not like a real
rapper but when he raps he's rapping
Killers anything like this [__] hard
because you believe them right like I've
had a lot of those like guys I have
rappers like that that I believe to be
real killers like when I would listen to
MLP as a kid I'd be like
yeah these [__] I'll kill your
ass yeah but it is different when you
know even like Fat Joe Like Fat Joe back
in the day after you hear all these
stories about Fat Joe [__] people up
and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um so so I would say like yeah I
listened to some some Benzino but Emma's
my favorite though
yeah and what's your favorite yeah and
what's my favorite so you were torn
because you're like the hometown I
wasn't like touring like I was like 90
Eminem like 10 Benzino but
I wouldn't just go against Benzino
because he's still from the 617 you know
what's your favorite uh Eminem album
um
this is it the um welcome to the Eminem
so damn it Eminem Show yeah that's my
favorite the third one say about a
Hollywood man when like and like just he
raps and like
I don't know but then I like The Slim
Shady
eplp everybody amen I've had I got I'm
gonna tell you right he said some of his
most illest intricate raps ever one like
that his first joint and Slim Shady yeah
but then he got so introspective like
from a rapping perspective that Slim
Shady LP is crazy right but then the
Eminem show
is incredible how like introspective he
got and [__] like that and I just think
he had the better records it's my
favorite M album yeah and then there was
Encore which was it then relapse
oh [__] has Eminem know who you are I
don't know man I'm not sure no [__]
it'd be kind of crazy [__] I feel
like he do yeah yeah I feel like I'm on
Drake's radar definitely because he's a
guy who um
you know Jake's really in tune with like
the rap [__] so how do you mean is there
anything that's happened where you think
like oh I'm on Drake's radar like
because of this because he likes
something people have told me [__] but
there's no like like concrete [__] right
you know that I can say but um
hopefully you know what I mean hopefully
I'm on M's radar too because like I
bodied a lot of Eminem beats my body a
lot of Drake beat [__] like that yeah